well there's uh two categories of folks
that you outline that uh that worry
about or highlight the risks of AI and
you highlight a bunch of different risks
I would love to go through those risks
and just discuss some brainstorm
which ones are serious and which ones
are less serious but first the Baptist
and the Bootleggers what are these two
interesting groups of folks
who are who who worry about uh the
effect of AI and human civilization or
say they do say okay
yes I'll say they do the Baptist Warrior
the Bootleggers I say they do yeah
um so the Baptist and the Bootleggers is
a metaphor from economics um from what's
called development economics and it's
this observation that when you get
social reform movements
um in a society you tend to get two sets
of people showing up arguing for the
social reform um and the the term
baptism Bootleggers comes from the
American experience with alcohol
prohibition and so in the 1900s 1910s
there was this movement that was very
passionate at the time which basically
said alcohol is the evil and it's
destroying Society by the way there was
a lot of evidence to support this
um there were very high rates of very
high correlations then by the way and
now between race of physical violence
and alcohol use almost all violent
crimes have either the perpetrator or
the victim are both drunk almost all if
you see this actually in the work almost
all social harassment cases the
workplace it's like at a company party
and somebody's drunk like it's it's
amazing how often alcohol actually
correlates to actually just dysfunction
at least to domestic abuse um and so
forth child abuse and so you had this
group of people who were like okay this
this is bad stuff and we should Outlaw
it and those were quite literally
Baptists those were super committed you
know hardcore Christian activists in a
lot of cases there was this woman uh
whose name was Carrie Nation
um who was this older woman who had been
in this you know I don't know disastrous
marriage or something and her husband
had been abusive and drunk all the time
and she became the icon of the Baptist
uh prohibitionist and she was legendary
in that era for carrying an ax
um and doing you know completely on her
own doing raids of saloons and like
taking her acts to all the bottles and
things in the back and and so so a True
Believer an absolute True Believer
um and with absolutely the purest of
intentions and again
there's a very important thing here it
which is there's you could look at this
cynically and you could say the Baptists
are like delusional you know extremists
but you could also say look they're
right like she was me you know she had a
point like she wasn't wrong
um about a lot of what she said yeah but
it turns out the way The Story Goes is
it turns out that there were another set
of people who very badly wanted to
outlaw alcohol in those days and those
were the Bootleggers which was organized
crime this stood to make a huge amount
of money if legal alcohol sales were
banned um and this was in fact the way
the history goes is this was actually
the beginning of organized crime in the
U.S this was the big Economic
Opportunity that opened that up
um and so they went in together
um and then they didn't go in together
like the Baptist did not even
necessarily know about the Bootleggers
because they were on their moral Crusade
The Bootlegger certainly knew about the
Baptists and they were like wow this is
these people are like the great front
people for like you know it's good PR
Shenanigans in the background yeah and
they got the full stud Act passed right
and they did in fact ban alcohol in the
U.S and you'll notice what happened
which is people kept drinking like it
didn't work and people kept drinking
um the Bootleggers made a tremendous
amount of money
um and then over time it became clear
that it made no sense to make it illegal
and it was causing more problems and so
then it was revoked and here we sit with
legal alcohol 100 years later with all
the same problems
um and you know the whole thing was this
like giant misadventure uh the Baptist
got taken advantage of by the
bootleggers and the Bootleggers got what
they wanted and and that was that the
same two categories of folks are now uh
sort of suggesting that uh the
development of artificial intelligence
should be regulated yeah it's the same
pattern and the the economists the same
pattern every time like this is what
happened with nuclear power this is what
happened which another interesting one
but like yeah this is this happens
dozens and dozens of times
um throughout the last hundred years and
and this is what's happening now